we have made you do updates on the
caravan tonight everything we've been
warning you is unfortunately being
proven true everything the media people
like Barack Obama everything they were
telling you completely false
that's the subject of tonight's mini
monologue still camped out in Tijuana
Mexico following clashes with the u.s.
Border Patrol officers Sunday just today
DHS released more information on what
are extremely dangerous conditions for
many people the high number of women who
are assaulted during this journey Grif
Jenkins reporting that some migrants are
actually self deporting as they face
diminishing prospects of entering the US
legally and he's also uncovering that
despite what the mainstream media has
been telling you the vast majority in
the caravan happened to be men and
health officials they're reporting that
one third of the people traveling in the
caravan are being treated for various
health issues including lice skin
infections three confirmed cases of
tuberculosis four confirmed cases of
chickenpox or more and by the way I
think we should shoot on a humanitarian
basis health but let it be clear I said
many times I want many people in the
caravan I know they're searching for a
better life but storming the border
attacking Border Patrol rocks bottles
other projectiles
that's not seeking asylum when when do
you so-called asylum seekers act like
that we're also learning tonight none of
the migrants involved in the clashes
will face any prosecution despite the
president's vow that lawlessness on the
border will not be tolerated
meanwhile the threat of more violence is
even prompting the Department of Justice
now to send DEA agents and US Marshal
Service personnel to Southern California
and just last night we learned that an
admitted ms-13 gang member was recently
arrested at the border crossing east of
Tijuana and he's been identified as a 29
year old Honduran telling authorities he
was part of the caravan despite mounting
evidence the media is continuing to
downplay that real threat all while
ignoring the failures of the Obama
administration and what they did oh they
shot pepper spray and tear gas at people
that tried to come into the country
illegally nobody reported on a dead you
wanting us now an hour a TV contributor
Dan bond Geno Fox
as contributor our friend Geraldo Rivera
for although you know you got me so mad
one night because I said to you I told
you this was coming
what do you want to do Sean you want to
shoot no I don't I I have acknowledged
to you how many times that I probably
99% want a better life and I sympathize
with that I really do my heart goes out
I want humanitarian health care we have
we can help them with TB and chicken we
need to do it but the problem is laws
sovereignty borders
that's what matters and the identified
criminals that have infiltrated the
caravan hello Dan I love you my brother
Shawn you know I stand shoulder to
shoulder with both of you and it comes
to exposing the Russia collusion
illusion but I think the harsh treatment
of those migrants at the border with the
pepper spray and all the rest of it the
mill sensation for southern border it
was it you know like it right John that
doesn't make it right and I charge in
your borders how would you do it of the
42 arrested eight were women with
children Shawn those scenes are etched
in our national psyche now lightly
separation agility over two months ago
friends in the Obama years go on you if
indeed these sins were committed during
the Obama administration that doesn't
make the sins being committed now right
okay we have that recollection but not
just what he to P we can't treat these
people like they're walking on you
virgins one ms-13 member do we do any
member among seventh out of 10,000
Geraldo what Dan what about our Border
Patrol guys rocks bottles projectiles
tear gas isn't going to kill you and I
think parents have a responsibility to
pull their kids away from that situation
that's their responsibility to yeah you
know or although again I appreciate your
nice comments I consider you a friend
too but you are way way off base on this
I've stood at roll calls I was a law
enforcement officer I'm out looking for
anybody's pat on the back your tax
dollars paid for it was a great job but
I
ask you the same question Sean asked you
you're given a lot of platitudes nobody
wants to see anybody tear gas
you win points stipulated we're both we
both are empathetic to that but that was
not the choice of the Border Patrol
officials the choice was made by people
who storm the border illegally and I ask
you a very simple question
and I would sincerely appreciate an
honest answer you're standing in the
face of these Border Patrol agents
patrolling our borders just doing their
jobs to keep our nation secure what do
you tell them to do when a rock comes at
their face what what's your answer you
nobody produces an answer they just
don't you don't what do you do this is
what you this is what you do not do dan
you did not shoot to your guidance you
and Blanche the greens or the great
grandsons of immigrants Italian
immigrants Irish immigrants they were
slandered just like you slandering these
people with these with these with these
and white polish and they they have
diseases I'll be bringing disease they
read the newspapers little of the 19th
century the Irish would bring in
diseases the Italian question this is a
slide these are like what you don't do
is you don't what do you order what do
you do all right here's what you do you
send spanish-speaking ambassadors to the
crowd you explain to them that they are
not going to be able to write the
borders you complain to them the facts
of the reality of what's happening
there's a stain on the Trump presidency
charging the border and charging at
police what if it's thousands what do
you do then that's an important question
you need to answer are you are you gonna
believe those gonna tell you to leave
your own lying eyes when you look at the
video and you see the composition of
this crowd
this makes benign cement civilian crack
rock you know the rock city three scenes
the three scenes of the
what about the scenes of them living in
squalor and in the in the athletic
fields you weren't legally wrong after
they have the they they're begging for
food and overflowing toilets and claim
the most inhumane conditions where we're
where is where is USA the leaders of a
border patrolling in the in the
statement idolization you're you're
suggesting you do it with humanity
dealing you deal with as many humanity
and compassion you let me just say this
if we had the wall nobody would get hurt
on the other side and we never grew one
little bit whoa let's feel all right we
couldn't we enter the room
[Music]